Bertrand il y a Charles Frick arrive il
arrive quand déjà il arrive mercredi j'y
pense avec un bordel alors dans Paris là
début d'après-midi ouais il arrive à
quelle heure en Eurostar gare du Nord
même si c'est pas encore officiellement
il arrive en Eurostar le gars oui bah
parce que écologique on sait qu'il aime
bien l'écologie défense et il trouve que
voilà c'est mieux que l'avion dans le
fond il a mis à l'écologie
14h30 on sait qu'en effet tout le
quartier de la Gare du Nord
monopolisé il sera quasiment à
praticable dans le 10e arrondissement
mais mercredi et ils seront ils vont
prendre place à bord d'une Bentley une
Bentley véhicule royale qui aurait été
acheminée en camion spéciale de
Buckingham Palace quelle couleur benzy
elle devrait être Cyril dans les
couleurs du palais dans les couleurs un
peu lis de va lit devant oui littlevard
un peu Bordeaux prune ils l'ont trouvé
où la Bentley bah c'était un des
véhicules ça fait partie de la flotte
royale ah ils l'ont ramené de
l'Angleterre absolument deux véhicules
au cas où il y en a une ah des deux qui
adresses à tomber en panne pourquoi une
Bentley parce qu'elle a la particularité
par en toi assez haut ah ouais et que
comme on est en voyage d'État les
oreilles du familia non Camilla va
arriver chapeauté et il va falloir
qu'elle rentre dans la voiture est
d'accord voilà un chapeau il commence au
chapeau je sais pas exactement comment
on fait le chapeau mais on peut quand
même estimer voilà je dEtat en France
que il va avoir un chapeau quand même
assez important ouais direction les
Champs-Élysées Cyril où ils vont déposer
une gerbe de force sur la tombe du
Soldat après ils sont pas bien avec le
voyage un truc quand ils vont déposer
une gerbe sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
ah merde
il devrait il devait venir en mars
dernier là ça a été annulé on se
souvient parce que souvenez-vous il y
avait des manifestations Paris étaient à
feu et à sang il faut en fait il vient
pourquoi il vient dans le cadre c'est
son 34e voyage en France mais le premier
depuis qu'il est roi il y a pour sceller
officiellement les dia d'amitié entre la
France et l'anglise c'est ce qu'on
appelle une visite d'État
serait durer deux secondes c'est terminé
ça va rapide deux jours et demi deux
jours vendredi alors il y avait qui il
vient avec Shania et sa meuf Kamila
c'est sa meuf la reine son mari
oui c'est son mari en 2007
[Rires]
de personnes secrétaire particulier
il faut savoir qu'on ne s'adresse pas
directement quoi vous le savez si
quelqu'un a une de Léan ça fait au roi
évidemment il doit passer par son
secrétaire
voilà non ça il va plutôt le faire à mon
avis à son valet c'est pas tellement
hack live qui va demander à côté
de l'oseille pour me prêter il a pas
d'argent sur lui non non on n'a jamais
d'argent sur lui il paye comment il paye
pas
on va voir on va voir s'il vient chez
moi s'il paye
rien à on paye pour lui ah bah
très bien alors il vient avec son
attaché de presse il vient avec son
presse-office son chef du bureau presse
qui vient avec un ostéopathe absolument
pourquoi il a mal où Erica bah au long
des cas il s'appelle il s'appelle Eric
ah d'accord Eric et dans son estomac de
nombreuses chutes de cheval
il vient avec son ostéopathe son matelas
et son oreiller
il dort très difficilement il va le
mettre où dans l'Eurostar ah mais tout
ça est en train d'être à cheminée pour
l'instant à l'hôtel et qu'il va occuper
à savoir l'ambassade de Grande-Bretagne
il va où il va dormir où elle ambassade
de Grande-Bretagne rue du faux pour
certaines les voisins d'Emmanuel et de
Brigitte Macron puisque le palais qui
disait au 55 ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne est occupante 9 ça fait
des voisins genre ils vont pouvoir faire
la fête de voisin
à nouveau de sécurité Cyril et c'est un
endroit remarquable l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne je ne sais pas si que
vous avez déjà eu l'occasion de sublime
c'est très très beau c'est l'occasion
c'est ma salle de Grande-Bretagne je
suis allé moi j'avais invité pour un
truc avec des potes là-bas
et alors il séjourneront dans une suite
du premier étage avec vue sur les
jardins nous dit-on deux chambres et à
la fois
et et ils ont cette suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ensemble non non je pense que c'est
comment dire c'est comme ça c'est voilà
c'est peut-être difficile à comprendre
mais c'est de la culture
est-ce qu'il va voir ailleurs est-ce que
c'est un chat
mais je t'assure que c'est des bruits
que l'on a pas pour le N il paraît il
paraît qu'elle est comme ça bouge pas
bah non bah elle bouge plus
calme-toi tu respectes non non non
elle est pas mal je trouve qu'elle est
mieux qu'avant moi mais pour le coup
c'est une vraie histoire d'amour c'est
une vraie histoire d'amour Camille va
être avec une maquilleuse une manucure
une femme de chambre personnelle
absolument une caméra comme on dit qui
va s'appeler Joe Ford et vous savez
johnsfort qui va avoir pour mission de
la de la maquiller et de la coiffer
alors surtout avoir pour mission le
mercredi soir vous savez il y a le grand
dîner de gala qui est offert au château
de Versailles c'est Versailles c'est
mercredi
la République va sortir tous les Orres
qu'elle a encore si leur veut dire en
effet Camilla va arriver alors robe
longue on pense black à la maison Dior
qui va être mise à l'honneur elle va
choisir une maison française pour être
habillée et elle va être elle va coiffer
un diadème il faut savoir que là sa
disposition 16 qui ont été hérités
d'Elisabeth II et parmi elle il y a
trois bandeaux quartiers on pense bien
qu'elle va choisir le quartier pour
mettre à nouveau comme ça avec un truc à
la Koh-Lanta là
en orfèvre
trois chefs triplement étoilés ont été
euh non
Anne-Sophie pique pour l'entrée elle n'a
pas encore dit ce qu'elle allait ce
qu'elle allait faire en tout cas elle
aurait aimé faire des asperges ce n'est
plus de saison et à l'état interdite de
foie gras c'est bien que Charles III
déteste ça il a été le foie gras servi
du foie gras et t'es pas il aime pas
Yannick Alleno pour le plat va servir de
la poularde de Bresse de coup tout ça de
la poularde de la poularde de Bresse
poché au champagne ah ouais quand même
avec une extraction de maïs
en gratin de cèpes non champignon
qui va faire son traditionnel et safran
il s'affront il se parle il s'affront
des conneries tu des conneries avec un
implant c'est un biscuit de macaron qui
est servi avec une compétée de
framboises et un sorbet à la rose et au
lit tout ça les gars là et qui est vendu
d'asperges ils vont faire quoi j'ai pas
compris
pour l'instant on ne la connais pas on
est venu pour nous dire ce qu'il y avait
pas à manger quoi à l'entrée moi aussi
je peux dire pas d'omelette ils
mangeront pas chaque Chouquet moi je
repars au Japan merguez je peux le dire
aussi frère c'est qu'on peut péter pour
nous dire ce qu'ils vont pas manger
c'est facile est-ce qu'on peut peut-être
dire parce que ça j'ai de la foi c'est
que rat de faire entre les équipes de
Buckingham apparemment et le palais de
l'émission
seulement assisterons à ce dîner quoi
parce que c'est la majorité c'est ce que
peut contenir la galerie des glaces qui
fait 6013 mètres la table va mesurer 66
m très exactement on peut donc asseoir
160 personnes et le palais de Buckingham
aurait déjà imposé sans inviter
personnelle qui veut donc dire
qu'Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron ont le
choix vous avez fait des calculs ah de
60 personnes sachant que les membres du
gouvernement déjà seront représentants
en grosse majorité ça ne laisse pas
énormément de place pour tous ceux qui
rêveraient de faire sortir de ce dîner
dans la chose on peut anecdotique et
drôle je trouve vous allez vraiment
sortir tous les ordres de la République
puisque le le service de porcelaine de
Sèvres qui va être utilisé date de 1750
8 et de Louis XV il va être acheminé par
la chancellerie du Palais de l'Élysée
qui a en charge l'argenterie c'est le
grand argentier du Palais de l'Élysée
qui va amener personnellement cette
vaisselle c'est un trésor d'État on sait
qu'il va y avoir au dîner ou pas un peu
alors on a pas les noms voilà il y a on
pense Christine Scott Thomas non là
l'actrice
on pense Lambert Wilson
un peu anglais
ou des trucs un peu alors on attend qu'à
Catherine Deneuve parce que son mari
vous savez David
était photographe de Isabelle 2
[Rires]
inès de la fraise est très proche de
Albert de Charles et de Camila ah ouais
on peut peut-être dire aussi voler
sécuritaire incroyable puisque c'est
voilà on reçoit un roi qui est en
fonction c'est à dire que l'ensemble des
membres du SDLP le service de la haute
protection qui a en charge la sécurité
des personnalités et monopolisées et on
attend aussi le raid alors les copains
du SPIP
et près de 1000 CRS puisque il va
surtout falloir sécuriser le transport
qui a lieu entre l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne et le château de
Versailles on parle quand même d'une
trentaine de kilomètres quand les voix
vont être coupées mais on porte 350
policiers vont sont monopoliser pour
suivre le véhicule et toutes les chaînes
d'information quasiment Cyril ont déjà
un programme pour suivre le dîner tu vas
être trou toi cuisine
non mais tu vas être un poisson
probablement dans la cour du château de
Versailles
ou quoi
tu vas être dans la cour prenant un
petit foot dans la cour on fait un kiffe
ce sera un peu l'idée on essaie quoi
alors tu vas être dans la cour et tu vas
faire quoi toi tu vas l'appeler quand tu
vas voir ça
va on va essayer en tout cas de voilà en
tout cas de d'avoir un mot là d'avoir un
mot voilà
tu pourras nous faire un truc c'est ce
qui est prévu on va essayer
en plus
c'est toi qui va faire le gugus le
château de Versailles c'est moi qui paye
plus ou moins elle m'a très bien tu as
bien fait de venir bravo mon chéri on
t'attend allez